♪ (explorative music) ♪
(applause)
Thank you all for
coming out this evening.
It really is an honor
and pleasure to be here
talking about
National Geographic,
and in somewhat of a light
that maybe some of you
know about and maybe some
of you don't know about.
I mean everybody knows
about the golden rectangle
and about the National
Geographic magazine .
Most of you know
about our channel
and the fact that
through our media
we reach almost four
hundred million souls
around the world.
It's incredible, it's
an honor to represent
National Geographic
but it's also equally
important to remember
that we are a funder
of research and that we are
a player, we're proactive.
Fredrik Hiebert: If we want
to tell the stories of people,
places, cultures,
ecology, whales and lions
and other things that
I don't deal with,
we have to preserve that!
We have to be able to
take care of our world
so that future generations,
our kids and their kids
will be able to turn
to National Geographic
and have the same
stories to be told.
You know, we have a very special
thing with history and culture.
It's very actually
different from you know
biological world or oceans
and things like that.
It's, the difference is
the culture, the past,
the remains of our
history is nonrenewable.
Like once a giant
Buddha is destroyed
it can't come back.
It's gone!
Once a site is destroyed
that little piece of history
that piece of peoples'
identity is gone.
You can't replace that
And so, we become really
sort of focused on
what can we do as a group,
as a bunch of you know,
drummers in a band
to get people so
that we can say,
yeah, we can actually
do something.
That's what this
evening is all about.
Fredrik: When we look at
the world and certainly that's
something that's
interesting about Geographic
is that we do have
as our research arena
all the continents of the world
even Antarctica,
we don't have that.
These circles here, these ovals
are centers of civilization,
centers of dense
archaeological finds.
As you can see, you
know we're looking at
something not on just
one continent or another.
We're not gonna talk
about all of these.
Tonight we're gonna look
at a few case examples.
But when we look at the
whole issue of you know,
how to keep cultures
and keep identities
and artifacts where they belong.
How is it that these
different cultures
can become proud of
their role in part
of human history in
defining humanity?
It's huge, it's
almost unbelievable.
When I work with
customs agents about
what's coming
through the airports
and what's coming
through our ports,
its, you know I show
them this picture
and I say, you have a
huge issue on your hands.
You could have you know,
artifacts from the Andes
just as easily as you can
have artifacts from Mali
just as easily as you can have
artifacts from Afghanistan
in a box being transported
away from its home.
How are you gonna
deal with that?
That's something which
is we're gonna talk
about those kind of
interesting topics tonight.
And we're gonna look at
a few of these areas.
I call these
archaeological hot spots.
And I'm happy to
tell you more about
those archaeological hot
spots in discussion.
But I'm gonna give
you a few examples.
I'll give two,
Afghanistan and Peru
just to tell you
a little bit about
approaches that we can have.
Very positive approaches
that we can help
to inspire these artifacts
and these cultures
to remain alive in the
countries where they are.
These are archaeologically
rich countries, right?
All of them, all of
them have so many
sites it's hard to count them.
Afghanistan is famous for
its role on the Silk road,
and we have artifacts
all over the place.
I think this was the
first country where we
had sort of an
international recognition
for a country's
cultural heritage
for something that we
wish really didn't happen.
This is a giant Buddha
in the Bamiyan Valley.
Huge, over a hundred feet tall,
incredible built in the sixth,
or seventh, or
eighth century A.D.
It's been famous.
It was a tourist attraction.
And many of you remember
when it was destroyed.
Fredrik: That sort of culture
destruction cannot be replaced.
And it, for the
first time focused
international
attention on you know,
the center of the
Silk road and say,
oh my goodness we
didn't really realize
that culture was a
big factor in this.
And I think when it was on the
front pages of the
New York Times,
when it was on the pages
of the National Geographic
when you saw this
on CNN you realize,
oh, this is important.
At the same time
people have to realize
that fragility of culture
wasn't just at Pompeion.
This is two thousand
and three when I
first saw the National
Museum of Afghanistan.
This is the museum.
No roof, no windows and
inside, no artifacts.
I went there on behalf
of National Geographic
magazine to sort of
write a post script
about what I thought
was a tragedy,
something that people
should know about.
But something else happened,
okay.
I went to the museum, all
the way to Afghanistan.
I had never actually been
to Afghanistan before
even though I had
written about it.
I had written reports
in archaeology magazines.
I wrote my dissertation on it.
It was sort of like,
I never thought
I was going to Afghanistan.
And I went and I talked to the
museum director, this
man Omara Khan Massoudi.
He's one of my cultural
heroes this evening is about.
And I said, "What do I say about
the treasures of Afghanistan?"
And he said, well you
know the treasures
of the National Museum
meant a lot to us
and you know before the museum
was destroyed we hid them away.
Well, he said that's a
secret but I'm telling you.
And we ended up doing
something that we never
expected to do at
National Geographic.
We sponsored
an inventory of the
hidden collections
of Afghanistan.
This is one of the pieces.
We put all these
things on inventory,
computerized, digital images
and we created a passport
for these objects.
That meant that
now these objects
were visible to the whole world
and could never actually
be sold or marketed again.
Kind of squashing a
market for these objects.
It also lead to the
Bactrian Gold exhibition.
They're feeling of sense of self
about this within Afghanistan.
A sense of great honor and
sort of cultural heritage
that they hadn't
seen for 30 years.
And that's a really
positive thing
that came out of working
together on that.
There are other problems
and we continue to work
with the Afghans on
issues on what happens
during the situation
when sites are looted.
This is actually
not an excavation.
These are people
who are just digging
for treasures in Afghanistan.
And it hurts me to
look at this picture.
My friend who excavated
the Bactrian Gold,
he took this picture
and here's a picture
of where those
artifacts ended up.
That's the marketplace in Kabul.
I can't tell you how many
four thousand year old
burials this represents 'cause
it's impossible
for me to say that.
But each one of those
vessels represents
a piece of culture which is out,
and about to be sent abroad
for pennies on each piece.
(stutters)
It's tragic from a
personal point of view,
from an Afghan point of view
and from a world
point of view to see.
That's a whole chapter
of history right there.
So we do, do things
and I am pleased
to say that work
with U.S. Customs.
We work with UNESCO.
We work with culture,
with groups around the world.
And one of the things
that we do is we help.
For example, this
is U.S. Customs.
This is a shipment of
illegally transported artifacts
that thanks to
collaboration between
the U.S. government
and the governments
around the world
including Afghanistan
and Peru and quite
a few countries.
We're able to say,
look these pieces
belong in a home and
they can be sent back.
And we're so pleased to be
able to say that repatriations
are an important part
of what we do here
at National Geographic,
here in Washington DC.
And the United
States is a really
good partner is
doing these things.
And I think it's
a fantastic thing
that you should all know about.
Let's turn quickly
to my second
example, which is Peru.
So we've moved continents.
This is a Peruvian pyramid.
Sometimes hard to see so I put
a little drawing
of a pyramid to say,
hey look, you know this
is just like Egypt.
You're gonna see some
pictures of pyramids later.
You know you've got pyramids
that are known from the
Mayan area from Egypt,
but believe me
they're in Peru too.
But pyramids attract the
attention of looters.
And things from those
pyramids have been
on sale in the market
for a long, long time.
This is a piece
from the exhibition
that was on the market in Italy.
We were so pleased
when the ambassador
from Peru asked the
president of Italy,
that's him in the front,
please return this piece of
Peruvian culture and they did.
And it was like ancient Rome
returning something
to ancient Peru.
I would've thought that,
that's kind of a
cool concept right?
We're really pleased
but you know it sat
for many years as
being kind of like,
okay, that's a large
cool mask, right?
What does it mean?
And you know without the context
of knowing what it is, it
was a little enigmatic.
Still very cool but
having the objects
in a database that
can be presented
to anybody as, you
know around the world.
This is the
Larco Museum in Peru,
which is a model.
The director of the
Larco Museum was here.
He has a collection of
45 thousand objects.
You can visit every single
one of these objects
in high resolution
because every single
object in their
collection is on the web.
I think that's fantastic!
We don't have museums in the
United States that have that.
And our best example
comes from Lima, Peru.
If you look very
carefully we have
a piece that was
stolen from Peru,
was returned by U.S. Customs.
It was at the Peruvian
embassy and they said
would you please
put this on display?
And I was like, oh
my God, that's huge.
And this piece has been
stolen twice from Peru.
'Cause the market is
so high for them.
We're trying to
reduce that market.
This piece, after
the exhibition will
be going back to Peru,
to its right home.
Peru is a nice example
because this is using drones
to document
archaeological sites in Peru.
We really are, you know
it's not just archaeologist
as Indiana Jones with
a shovel and a whip.
We use drones, we
use satellites.
We use best technology
available to help us understand
and preserve cultures
for the world.
Omara Massoudi: A nation
stays alive.
When its culture, stays alive.
Omara: Our people should
know what happened.
They should know
about their culture
about their history.
That is true for every
culture around the world.
They should know
about their culture.
about their history.
It's a win, win
situation for everybody.
We need
to do the inventory of
the collections and sites.
We need to help with
the repatriations.
And we need to
get people excited
about visiting these countries
where they come
from, like Egypt.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
♪ (gentle peaceful music) ♪
(English US - SDH)